Everything I told you last time,
you can summarize in these two equations.
Okay.
Do you remember what we did?
We said,
let's take for the simplest case
that we can possibly imagine,
namely a particle moving in one dimension
along the x axis with a constant
acceleration, a what is
the fate of this particle?
And the answer was at any time t the
location of the particle is given by this
formula.
Yeah,
you can easily check by
taking two derivatives.
This particle does have
the acceleration a,
so what are these two other numbers?
X Zero and V zero x, not in Vienna.
I think we know what they mean.
They're tell you the initial location
and initial velocity of the object.
For example,
suppose you use vertical motion and use
y instead of x and a would be g r minus
G. That's a particle falling
down under the effect of gravity.
If all you know is the particular is
falling out of the effect of gravity,
that's not enough to say
where the particle is, right?
Suppose we all go to a tall building,
start throwing things at various times,
various speeds. We're all throwing
objects was acceleration is minus g,
but the objects that are different
locations at a given time,
that's because they could have been
released from different heights with
different initial velocities.
Therefore,
it's not simply enough to
say what the acceleration is.
You have to give these two numbers.
Then once you got those two numbers
that no longer free parameters,
they are concrete numbers,
maybe five and nine, 10 foot.
Anytime t you plug into at the time
t and you will get the location.
If you took the derivative of this,
we'd get the velocity at time.
T two B v not plus eight t again,
you shouldn't memorize the formula. I
hope you know why it makes sense, right?
You want know how fast the guy is
moving this, the starting speed,
that's the rate that we did is gaining
velocity and that's how long it's been
gaining it.
So you add the two.
This also means the following.
It is true that if you give me the time,
I can tell you the velocity,
but conversely,
if I knew the velocity of this object,
I also know what time it is probated.
I knew the initial velocity.
Therefore mathematically
I'd they given time tea,
we can trade t four V and
put it into this formula,
vanish tea everywhere by doing it.
I got this formula.
Yeah
is a mattress, simple Algebra of
taking this and putting it here.
But I showed you in the end how you
can use calculus to derive that.
And I got the feeling when I was talking
to some of you guys that maybe you
should brush up on your calculus.
You have done it before. But uh,
when you say I know calculus,
sometimes it means you know,
it sometimes it means you know,
some fellow who does or you met somebody
who knows that's not good enough.
You really have to know calculus
and this is a constant problem.
It's nothing to do with uh,
you guys said.
It's just that you have
done it at various times.
It's a problem we have dealt with in
the physics department year after year.
And one solution for that is to get a
copy of the textbook I wrote called basic
training in mathematics.
It's about paper back or 30 bucks.
And I will, I've given the name of
the book in the classes website.
If I hadn't written it I would prescribe
it. But that is a little awkward moment.
You don't want to sell your own book.
On the other hand,
you don't have to withhold information
that may be useful to the class.
So I think that book will give you all
the basic principles you need in calculus
one variable more variables,
elementary, complex numbers,
maybe solving some problems
with vectors and so on,
which are going to get into whether you're
going to physics or not is irrelevant.
If you're going to any
science that uses mathematics,
chemistry or engineering
or even economics,
you should find the contents
of that useful. So I think, uh,
it'll be in your interest to
get that anywhere you like.
You can go to Amazon or you can go to
our bookstore bookstore has some copies,
but they're really for another course.
So you should look at it then
order it on your own. Okay.
So I will now proceed to the
actual subject matter for today.
So I told you,
the way I'm going to teach any subject
is going to start with the easiest
example and lull you into some kind of
security and then slowly increase the
difficulty.
So what's the next difficult thing?
Next difficult thing is to consider
a motion in higher dimensions.
So how high do you want to go?
Now for most of us,
we can go up to three dimensions because
we know we live in a three dimensional
world. Everything moves around in three
d that that'll be enough for this course.
In fact,
I'm going to use only two dimensions for
most of the time because the difference
between one dimension and two is very
great between two and three and four and
so on.
It's not very different.
There's only one occasion where it helps
to go to three dimensions because at a
certain things you can do in three
d you cannot do in less than freely,
but that's later. So we don't have to
worry about that. So we'll stop it too.
If you talk to the string theorists,
they will tell you that are really,
how many dimensions do you know
that are actually 10 including space and
times that are nine spatial dimensions.
That's according string guys.
So mathematicians are likely lead told
us how to analyze a mathematics in any
number of dimensions.
We don't pay attention to them when they
are going beyond three but now we know
we need that.
We're going to do too.
So our picture now,
it's going to be some particle
that's traveling in the x y plane.
So the guy who's just
moving around like this,
this is not an experts as time
plot at white versus time.
This the actual motion of the particle
and if you say where this time,
but one way to mark climates,
they imagined that it carries a clock
as it moves and put markers every second
that may be a t equal to zero t equals
to one t equal the two and so on.
So time is measured as a parameter
along the motion of the particles.
It is not explicitly shown,
but you can sort of tell the particles
moving slowly or rapidly by looking at
the space in between these tick marks.
For example here in one second it went
from here to here, he hadn't one second.
It seems to have gone much
further so probably is traveling
faster.
But if you want to describe this particle,
what's the kinematics?
You can pick a point and
say I am at the point x y.
So when you go to two dimensions,
you need a pair of numbers
instead of x you need x and y.
But what we will find is
this more convenience to
lump these two numbers in the
single entity,
which is called a vector.
So that's what we're going
to talk about a little bit.
Talk a little bit about vectors.
Now you guys,
I've also seen vectors,
I'm pretty sure,
but it is worth going over some properties
and some may be new and some may be
old.
So the simplest context in which one can
motivate a vector and also motivate the
rules for dealing with vectors
is when you look at a real space.
I mean just caught and it's x
and y and let's imagine that the,
I went on a camping trip and on
the first day here is where I was.
Then I tell you,
I went for five kilometers on the second
day and another five kilometers in the
third day. Then I asked you, where am I?
How far am I from camp?
You realize that you cannot answer that.
You cannot answer that. Even if I
promise to move only along the x axis,
because as I think,
I don't want to post this as a question
because I think the answer is fairly
obvious to everybody. It's not enough
to say, I went five kilometers.
I got to tell you whether I went to the
right or whether I went to the left,
so I could be 10 kilometers from home.
I could be zero kilometers from home,
or I could be minus 10 if I
had gone two steps to the left.
But you can deal with this bike
saying not just five kilometers,
but plus or minus five kilometers.
If you give a sign on top of the number
that takes care of all ambiguity in one
dimension. So assigned a number is
adequate to keep track of my emotion.
But you know in two d the options that
are just left and right or north and
south, but infinity of possible
directions in which I could go.
There's five kilometers.
So what I could do on the first day is
to come here on the second day could be
to go there.
These two guys are five kilometers long
for that purpose to describe that
displacement, we use a vector,
this is called a vector.
Going to give it a name a,
it starts from the origin
and goes to this point.
That is a description of what I did on
the first day and the second day I did
this and that is the description
of what it did on the second day.
But proper way to draw
vector is to draw an arrow.
It's got a beginning and it's got an ad.
Yeah.
So this is the reason behind seeing a
vector as a magnitude and direction.
Well magnitude is how long this guy isn't.
That action is at what angle it is,
so this is a, and this is B and now
you realize that, oh by the way,
when you draw a vector like a,
you're supposed to put a little arrow on
top. If you don't put an Arrow on top,
it means you're talking about just a
number a which could be positive or
negative or complex,
but it's just an ordinary number.
If you want to talk about
an Arrow of any kind,
you got to put a little arrow
on top of it. In a textbook,
they use boldface letters and classroom.
You use the symbol like this is a,
this is B.
It's a very natural quantity
that you can call a plus B.
If you want to call something as a plus B,
it means that I did a and then I did B,
but if I want to do it all in one shot,
what is the equivalence
step I should take?
It's obvious that the bottom line of
my two day trip is this object C and we
will call that a plus B.
It does represent the sum in the sense
that if I gave you four bucks and then
gave you five bucks,
I gave you effectively nine.
Here we are not talking
about a single number,
but a displacement in the plane and
see in d represents an effective
displacement.
This is the rule for adding vectors and
it has an origin in the simple example.
Okay,
so rule for adding the two vectors is
you draw the first one and at the end of
that first one you begin the second one
and the sun starts at the beginning of
the and and said the end of the second.
Okay? So that tells you how to
add two vectors and get a song.
You can verify in this simple example
that a plus B is the same as B plus a,
B plus h would be first Robbie.
And from there you draw a and you
will end up with the same point.
So you say this is a community of law.
It doesn't matter the sequence
in which you add the two vectors.
We know that's true for ordinary numbers,
right?
Three plus four and four plus years.
Same is also true for factors,
but the off composition
is not always commuted.
That are certain occasions in which
you first do a and then you do B.
That's not the same as far as doing B
and then doing a come to that later.
Right now this is the simple law.
All right?
Next thing I want to do is to define a
vector that plays the role of the number
zero, the number zero as a property
when you added to any number,
it doesn't make a difference.
I want a vector that I want to call
the zero vector and it should have the
property that I added to anybody.
I get the same vector
so you can guess who the zero of activist
zero vectors vector of no length.
I cannot. If this is a, I'm
going to drive back to here,
I cannot show you the zero vac.
The minute you can see it,
I'm doing something wrong,
right? If you can see it,
it's wrong because it's not
supposed to have any length,
but it has a property that when you add
it to anything, you get the same vector.
So that vector is called the null vector.
How about this guy?
I draw a,
then I draw another day.
Okay.
This is a plus.
A
No.
You have to agree that there's any vector
that deserved be called to a is this
guy, right? This is a plus a,
so we're going to call it to a,
the beauty of that is now we have
discovered a notion of what it means to
multiply the vector by a number.
If you multiply it by two you
get a vector two times as long,
but then you're able to generalize that
and say if you're multiplied by 2.6 I
mean a vector 2.6 hours long.
I see.
So multiplying vector by a number
means stretch it by the factor.
Then I want to think of a vector
that I can call minus eight
what do I expect of minus EI?
I expect that if it had minus a to a,
I should get the guy who plays
at all at zero in this world,
which is the vector of no length
is very clear that if you want to take
a and ask what should the APP to a play
get the nol vector,
it's clear that you want to add a vector
that looks like that because then if
you go from the start of
this to the finish of that,
you end up at the same point and you
get this invisible pseudo vector,
so the minus vector is that the same
vector flipped over to point the opposite
way. That's like minus one times
the vector. Once you got that,
you can do minus seven times of
vector minus Pi Times the vector.
Just take the vector multiplied
by Pi and flip it over.
That's minus Pi Times the vector.
This sub,
you get the rules for adding a vector to
another vector than taking a vector and
multiplying it by some constant.
Then of course you can do
more complicated things.
You can take this vector multiplied
by one number, take that vector,
multiply in other number,
add the two of them.
We know what all does operations mean.
No,
but you don't have to memorize all this.
There's only rulers.
Do what comes naturally to what you would
normally do with ordinating numbers in
the seems to work for vectors.
But you should know about multiplying
vector by a number of means.
All right, so this is the
notion of what vectors are not.
We are going to come to
some important concept,
which is the following.
You go back to the same x white plane.
Yeah.
There's some vectors. A gonna
introduce two very special vectors.
They're called a unit vectors.
And this guy I, that is Jay.
If I had a third access, I would
draw a k, but we don't need that.
So I and J are vectors of length
one pointing along x and Y.
Okay?
The claim is I can write any vector.
They give me us a rescale.
I plus a rescale.
Jay,
there's nothing you can throw at me that
I cannot handle with some multiple of
ions, some multiple of Jay.
No, it's intuitively clear,
but I will just prove it beyond any
doubt. Here's the vector. The A,
it is clear that that vector is the sum
of that vector and that vector by the
rules of accurate dish.
Right?
Because that plus that is equal
to the a but how about this part?
This part being paralleled to,
I has to be a multiple level high.
We know that because you can stretch.
I buy whatever factory life.
So whatever number it takes a x times.
I use this part,
this part being paralleled to Jay has
to be some multiple of jam going to call
it a y. Therefore, the fact
that aid that you gave me,
I have managed to write as
I times x let's j times a y.
So you can ask yourself, if you
gave me a particular vector, uh,
what do I use for x and a y?
[inaudible] you can see from trigonometry
that this angle will stay there, here
and the, the length of the
vector, I'm going to call by EI.
Ei is the length
of the,
if you drop the Arrow,
it's the usual convention.
As you're talking about the
length of the wreck today.
Okay.
First of all,
it's clear from the Pythagoras theorem
that ey is square root of x squared
plus eight wide square
and the angle Taita that it makes with
the x axis satisfies the condition time
Tito a y over the air.
So what this means now, here's the main
point. If you give me a pair of numbers,
a x and a y,
that's as good as giving me this Arrow
because I can find the length of the
Arrow by Pythagoras theorem and I could
find the orientation of the Arrow by
saying the angle Taito satisfied.
Stamped it is a boy over there.
Yes.
So you have the option of either working
with the two components of a odd with
the Arrow?
No,
in practice, most of the time the work
with these two numbers, a x and a y.
Yeah.
If you're describing a
particle with location, are
the vector be used typically to locate
the particles are than r is just I times
x plus j times.
Why?
Because you all know
that's x and that's why
no, I've not given you any other
example besides the displacement vector,
but at the moment we'll define a vector
to be any object which looks like some
multiple of Aipla,
some multiple of Jay.
So suppose I tell you to
add two vectors a and B
equal to c and I say, what's the result
of adding a and B? You got two options.
You can draw the Arrow corresponding to a,
then you make an Arrow corresponding to
be laid on the edge of this one that add
them as shown here.
Okay?
But you can also do
something with a drawing.
Any pictures that would come by saying,
I'm taking I times x Plus j
times a y plus I times dx.
Let Dave Times be why and I'm
trying to add all these guys,
but then I combine it time say x was
I times be x because that's the vector
paddle to I the length, the x, that's
the vector pilot. Do I with length be x?
It's clear if I add them,
I would get a vector parallel
to eye for the links X. Plus bx.
Then Jake will a wife.
Let's be why.
I have to be really careful
when I said I had the lengths.
I'm assuming all the components or
positive x and a y. Some are positive,
some are negative.
This is the way by which we are.
We have learned we should
combine multiple supply.
When I give you a multiple of
iron and other multiple of either,
some has got assets coefficient,
the sum of the two coefficients.
This is when you add two vectors.
You just add the components so that
if this vector is called I time see
explicitly eight times.
See why.
Then it's worth knowing
that CX is a explicit bx
and see why is a why plus B y.
So most of the time when
we deal with vectors,
we don't draw these arrows anymore.
We just keep a pair of numbers and if
you give me another vector that's another
pair of numbers and if you say add
the vectors, I will decide the x two,
the x and the y to the y and I
keeping track of what the summer is.
A very important result is
that if two vectors are equal,
if a equals B,
the only way it can happen
is if separately x is equal
to be x and a y is equal
to B.
Why?
That's the very important difference.
You cannot have two vectors equal
with exactly the same x component.
Exactly the same way component. That's
pretty obvious. If two arrows are equal,
you cannot be longer than the esthetician
and correspondingly shorter the white
election, everything has to completely
match. So back to the equation,
e equals B is actually a
shorthand for two equations.
They export some match
in the white parts mass.
Okay. Now when you work
with components x and a y,
if I didn't mention it,
the other components of the vector,
so you can do all your bookkeeping
in terms of aics anyway,
but he got to be aware of one fact.
If I just come and say to you here,
here's the vector whose
components three and five.
Can you draw the vector for me? Can you
draw it or not? Cause anybody have a view?
Yes. No, yes, no. Pardon me.
Yeah. If if you immediately said,
well, if the vector is three,
four then the vector looks like this.
You're making the assumption that I am
writing the vector in terms of I and G,
I see I n g s but in natural direction.
For most of us gravity acts this way,
defines the vertical direction very
naturally than the blackboard is oriented.
This way.
It should be a natural to call that x
and a call that y and lineup or axes.
What do you agree that there is no reason
why somebody else gonna come along and
say, you know what? I want to
use a different set of axes.
Those directions are more natural for me.
In fact,
just because the world is around,
you can already see this is the earth
to somebody that's a natural direction.
If you go to another neighboring country,
that's what they think
is naturally x and wife.
There is no reason why x and y
are nailed an absolute space.
It's very important that x and y are
human constructs and we're not wedded to
any of them quite often as natural
to pick x and Y in a certain way.
If you're studying a predict
child near the earth,
it makes sense to pick the
horizontal is x and vertical is y,
but mathematically you don't have to.
It's a very important point
that comes up is the following.
What if somebody comes along and has got
a new access and here's a unit vector I
prime,
that's unit vector j prime and here's
this vector a and the angle between my
access let's say,
and your access is some angle Phi.
The same vector at a can be written either
in terms of I and J are in terms of I
prime and j prime.
So let's take a minute to just play this
game of asking how were the compliments
of a in the new rotated coordinate
system related to the components,
the old coordinate system. This is a
simple problem but I just want to do it.
So you get used to working with vectors.
So the point is the ADOT a,
somebody is chosen the right in terms
of Ip crime and j prime as a prime and a
white print.
You guys follow that?
I prime a j prime but now rotated unit
vectors and somebody wants to think in
terms of those.
In other words,
the person who wants to ask how much
I've tried him, how my j prime need,
do I need to build up the Vec today?
That person would get a different answer.
You're asking how much I and how much
do I need to build the same object.
So the same entity written
in two different ways.
So
she's got a pair of numbers
and you got a pair of numbers.
The numbers are called the prime numbers
and you want to write them in terms of
yours. But for that, what do you need?
You need to know what I
primus in terms of ing.
So let's draw a little picture on
the side here. This is Ip crime.
It's got a link to one.
It's an angle Phi.
So
I'm going to write something and I'll
wait till you guys tell me you are
comfortable with this.
I try miss I co signed
fi plus j sine fine.
There should not be anybody in this
room is mystified by this statement.
This vector I prime has got a horizontal
part which is it's linked with just one
time score signed Phi and the vertical
part, which is one times signed Phi.
This kind of trigonometry you
should know all the time. Okay.
It's not something you're going to go
back and remember he said opposite side is
that or do some site.
You got to know that really well so you've
got to be very used to the notion of
taking it back it in some oblique.
That action writing it in terms of ing,
how bout j Prime Day prime is
pointing in that direction.
It's at an angle Phi
so j prime
would be minus I signed fine.
Plus j equals sign five
if it's not obvious,
I think this is the kind
of thing you should fill in
the blanks when you go home,
leave aligned there and think about
it and fill in the blanks later.
Very important to know if
these two axes at an angle Phi,
those two axes are also wrangled.
Fine.
That's the design to use
all the time and mechanics.
So once you do that,
I think it's fairly clear that it has
got a weight component that's given by
coast sign and x component that's given
by sign fi but x component is negative.
This vector as a little
bit of negative ions.
Here's what I say you should do and this
is the kind of thing I don't want to do
in classroom. It takes time and
I'm probably going to screw up.
So imagine taking I prime and j
prime and stick them here and here
do this in your head and
ask what can I possibly get?
I prime and j prime had been banished
everywhere they replaced by I and J so you
can now collect the whole expression as
something something I plus something.
Something Jay and what you will get four.
I will be x course sign fi minus a y sign
fi than here you will get a white Kosa
in FY plus x sign five.
Okay.
This is the only part I
don't want to do explicitly.
I'm just saying take this and
put it there and combined Imj
but this is the same vector.
We are calling it a
times x plus j times 81
and I've totally of two vectors that
equal the components mismatch I made then.
I'm sorry I'm making a mistake here.
This should be primed.
Okay.
By the way, when you guys do this,
did anybody notice subprime? Yeah,
so if you noticed it,
you got to stop.
You cannot let me write
anything that's incorrect.
So you've got to follow it in some detail.
I know you couldn't do the details,
but you should at least know that is I
prime and j prime that have been replaced
by I and j. But a experiment, a prime
will continue to be the coefficients.
So if I make the comparison,
I find x is equal to x prime cosigned Phi
minus a white prime signed Phi and a
y is equal to minus x prime sign Fi.
Let's say y prime cosigned Phi.
So what's the purpose of the exercise?
Purpose of the exercise
is to make the following
precisely to remark.
You can pick your unit vectors are
what are called basis vectors anyway.
You like pick any two
perpendicular directions which
may be related to the ones
I picked by an angle.
Phi. Then the same entity,
the same Arrow we test an existence
of its own independent of axes can be
described by you and me
using different numbers.
That's the precise connection between
the numbers you use the numbers.
I use your numbers. The prime on it
are related to mind by this relation.
No.
You can ask the opposite question.
How do I get your numbers
in terms of my numbers,
so what should I do?
They want inward.
The relation. Anybody have an
idea of what I should do now?
No one has a clue on how.
Why can go back from these to that.
Let me take a second to ask.
Do you have any idea what you should do?
Okay.
Maybe you are a yes.
Yep.
Expressions
are a prime x for every eight x and vice
versa and then just using the negative
negative a fee. Yes. Okay. All right,
so his idea was the formula written for
the opposite one will have the opposite
angle replaces five by minus of that.
Now that turns out to be the
correct answer, but I will.
I want you to guys to think about why
it was difficult to do it another way,
which is more pedestrian.
I mean if I told you a three x plus two
is nine and four x plus six is six you
certainly know how to solve for x and Y,
right?
This is something you've
seen in your high school.
You got to juggle the two equations,
multiply that by four,
multiply that by three and
add and subtract and so on.
Why is it when you saw this,
you didn't realize it's the same problem,
but it's the same problem. It's
fine. You said angle sine and cosine.
Definitely numbers.
If I pick an angle of 60 degrees,
these are some numbers like half
and root three over to that.
I'm trying to write uh,
these two unknowns in terms of these
two loans and they can solve for them
here though, what you will multiply by
would be signed fines and costs and five,
so you can eliminate,
for example,
if you multiply this by sign five and
multiply this by course and fire an add
them x prime will drop out.
So that's the kind of thing you should do.
Maybe you should,
I will add this on as a problem.
You should do it in the homework,
but do you realize that this is pair of
simultaneous equations in which you can
solve for these two unknowns if you like,
in terms of these two nodes
and these coefficients,
which are like these numbers
three to four and six,
you can do that.
But we like to get the answer the way
this gentleman described it because we'd
like to get an answer more readily
than by doing the mundane work.
And the idea that he had was,
if you go from me to you
with a clockwise rotation,
you go from you to me by
counterclockwise rotation. Therefore,
if I, my angle, if I go by fi to you,
then you must go by minus five
to come to me. That's correct.
So you will find them.
The result is aix course and fine.
Let's say sign fine.
I'm using the fact that when you take a
course sign and change the angle inside
the code sign,
it doesn't care.
But if you go to the sign
and change the angle inside,
the sign becomes minus side.
In other words,
sign of minus theta is minus sine
data and of course then of minus data,
this goes same data.
These by the way,
is another property I expect people to
know in this course. You cannot say,
I've never heard of it,
but I don't know where it came from.
We should think about why that is true.
Okay? So if you do that, it
will find then this result.
Okay.
So
that is a way to go from the unprime
coordinates the prime coordinate by
rotating our axes and actually
calculating the component.
No, he is a very important
message which is the following.
When you go from one set of axes to
another set of axes, the numbers change,
the competence,
the vector are not the same.
You might think it's all along x and
somebody can tell me it's all along my new
y axis. So the carpenters,
the vector or not invariant,
the depending on who is
looking at the vector,
but there's one quantity that's going
to come out the same no matter who is
looking at the vector.
Anybody have a guess on yes.
The length of the vector is
the length of the vector.
Perhaps it's clear to you that no
matter how your axis are oriented,
when you ask how long is this Arrow,
you're going to get the same answer and
that means x squared plus a white square
is a x prime square,
just a white prime square and that's
a property of this expression.
You can square to this guy and I added
to the square of this guy and you will
find using the magics of
trigonometry that this is true.
Now I'm going over at point because
they're very, very important.
When we do relativity,
we'll be dealing with vectors in space
time and that we'll find that a different
observers disagree on what
is this and what does that,
but they will agree on certain things.
Yes.
So is there a mindset
that have both the a lot
here? Hold on a sec. Here.
Lights.
This is a minus and that doesn't have
a minus on the other side over here.
Yeah, no, he had bought her
plus, but this one has in mind.
Oh, I'm so sorry. Yes, that
is correct. Thank you. Yes,
that's right. The minus is
only at, they're very good.
So certain things I'd call in variants.
This is an example of an invariant.
Okay.
By the way, I want to conclude
with one important point.
We learned that the vector is a quantity.
That is a magnitude and the direction.
But actually the view of vectors we take
nowadays is that a vector is a pair of
numbers are associated with a pair of
numbers with under rotation of axes
transform like this. Anything
that transformed this
way, it's called a vector.
Yeah.
All right, so now am I want
to ask the following question?
Can I manufacture new vectors?
We got one vector, which is our whole
board more vectors or position vectors.
So I want to look at that.
That turns out to be a very nice way
to produce vectors given one vector,
the position vector,
and that's the following.
Let's take a particle
that is moving in the x,
y plane, so that at one instant, sorry,
let me change this graph you'd
see here, oh, this is bad.
Oh,
let's see. It was moving like this.
So I'm here now a little later.
I am there. That's what I
meant. So this is called our,
this is called Delta r.
This is called our plus Delta R.
Yeah.
So the particles moving along this arc
initially is location as a function of
time is equal to I x of t plus j times
YFT.
If you wait the short amount of time
it goes to the new location which I am.
I'm going to call RF t plus Delta t.
What can that be?
It can be x of t plus some change in x
plus j times y of t plus the change in y.
Yeah,
that'd be recognized to be art at time
t plus everything else which is I times
delta x let's date times delta.
Why I'm going to call this
guy at pioneer vector Delta R.
Yeah. Other words if any more on
the line you wait a small time.
Delta t you move by an amount.
Delta x when they move in the plane,
your changes itself. A vector. You started
the vector, you changed by this vector.
Delta r it gives you the new location.
Delta Art has got two components.
It's garden changing.
Accent has got to change and why.
Therefore we will define what's called
the velocity vector, which is a,
if you want the limit as Delta t goes
to zero of Delta r over Delta t and you
can see that it's going to be,
I times Dxdt let j times the windy city.
So you can actually take
derivatives of a vector with time
and that's also a vector. Why is the
database of a vector also vector?
Because the difference in
the vector between two times,
this is vector dividing by Delta T.
It's like multiplying by one over Delta
t but I know when I multiply the vector
by a number,
I get a vector in the same direction.
So what does really means is that if you
take the limit as Delta t goes to zero,
I cannot dry it that well,
but imagine bringing the second point
closer and closer to the first one, Delta.
Ours getting very small,
Delta t is very, very small,
but by the miracle of calculus, the
ratio will approach the definite limit.
That limit will be some arrow.
You can call the velocity at that time
and an always be tangent to the curve
because tangents pointing towards the
direction you're headed at that instance.
So
if I gave
you the location of a particle
is a function of time,
you can find the velocity by
taking databases. For example,
if I say a particle's location is I
times t square flooded times 90 cubed,
but every value of time you can put the
numbers in and you can find the velocity
by just taking derivatives.
Did a way to have this guy will be two
times I plus what at 2017 square times
Jay.
So rule for taking derivatives.
If you want to do just mindless
application of calculus, you can do it.
I and J are constant.
Ignore them and you take
derivatives x and y depends on time.
Just take the deliberative and that's
the velocity vector and you can take an
Dell it deliver to off the derivative
and it can get the acceleration vector
will be d two are over d t square
and you can also write it as DVD t.
Okay.
Any,
anybody have questions with what I've
done now or what we're doing here?
Let me summarize what I'm
saying. Particles moving in
a plane at every instant.
It's got a location given by the vector
are art itself is contained in a pair of
numbers x and y and they vary with time.
So when you very time a little bit and
ask how does are changed and you take the
caution of Delta Art,
the Delta t you get the velocity vector
mathematically is done by taking the
expression for r and differentiating
everything in sight that can be
differentiated Spec to t.
So even though we started with a single
vector, which is the position vector,
we are now finding out that
is deliberative has to be
a vector and the data to
deliver it is also a vector. Again,
when he learned a little nutty,
you will find out there's one
vector that staring at you.
I'll come to what that is.
That's the analog or the position vector.
But more than more vectors can
be manufactured by taking it.
Yes.
Okay,
so now I want to do one concrete problem
where you will see how to use these a
bit of bitters.
I'm going to write the particular case
of art of tea and take derivatives and
we'll get a feeling for what's going on.
The problem I have in mind looks like
this RFT is going to be a fixed number of
our
I times square sine Omega t time.
Sine Omega t
does Omega as a new creature.
You don't know what it is right now,
but I'm going to just put
that in and Omega time.
Sti is some number and it's of course
saint of the number of times I plus sign
of the number of times j times are
so what is going on? That's a function
of time. What's this particle doing?
First thing you can tell is that if
you find the length of this vector,
you will find the square of the
x and the square or the white,
but it's in science squared
plus [inaudible] squared is one.
You'll find this back as a fixed length
r that means it can only be rattling
around in a circle of radius r
and in fact,
what the guy is doing looks like this
at any given time. T drawn angle,
Omega t and a radius r and
that's very a particularist.
You see that because the x component of
this one in our course and Omega t and
the white part is our sine Omega
three s Omega is a fixed number.
As t increases, this angle increases
and the particle goes round and round.
So we're describing the
motion of a polygon. A circle.
Yeah.
Now let's understand what Omega is.
Let's get a feeling for omega.
As time increases,
the angle increases and we can ask how
long does it take for the particle to
come back to the starting point up.
The starting point was here.
So as the increased little t omega t
will increase and I want to come back to
where I start.
So you've got to ask yourself,
let the time it takes to do a full circle.
That's the time period.
Do a full circle
and what can you say?
Abort Omega t what should it be?
The valley of Omega t
very good, so you can say it's
three 60 degrees, that's fine,
but we like to measure angle and Radians.
Now how many people know about radiants?
Okay.
For those who have not seen a radiant
it just another way to measure the angle
with the understanding
that if full circle,
which we used to think of three 60 degrees
is equal to two Pi Radians to pious,
roughly six so radiant is roughly
60 degrees is 58 and fraction.
Why do you like the measure
of angle in the peculiar way?
You will see the advantages of that later,
but we'll adapt the convention that will
measure the angle in the radio so that
a half circle,
instead of calling it one 80 degrees,
you will call it as pie and a quarter
circle instead of 90 we'll call it pi over
two and 45 is by our Ford and so on,
but it's good to know a certain
famous angles. This is Pi over two.
This is Pi is Pi over two
and this is back to two Pi.
Therefore Omega t equals two Pi tells
you that Omega is two Pi divided by the
time it takes to complete it.
Evolution
in one over the time period
is what we call the frequency.
You can write it as f is
just the usual frequency.
60 Hertz means you'll do
60 revolutions per second.
All right, so how fast
is this particle moving?
It's going to go around the circle.
The angle is increasing at a steady rate,
so we know it's going at a steady speed.
I'm asking what's the tangential
speed as it moves along the circle?
Yes.
How do you reach that conclusion?
I agree,
but I want the speed in meters per
second and Omega will be in radiance per
second. Yes. And how did you get that?
Okay,
but
that's correct.
But let me did use that in another way.
Your answers completely correct.
It is Omega are,
but I want to say how you get it. One
way is to say, if I do a full revolution,
I think of the speed as the distance.
Over time I'm going to
go one full revolution.
This sensor travel is to PR
but two Pi over t was identified as Omega.
So the tangential velocity or at any
point is equal to Omega Times are.
That's a useful quantity to know.
So now you can take this velocity
and you can take this are the,
let me find the Ft.
The FT is obtained by taking deliberate
to this expression and I think you guys
know enough calculus for me to write
is equal to my, it's equal to uh,
our
times.
I times minus Omega Sine Omega t
plus j times Omega Cosine Omega t.
That is the velocity of this guy.
And I invite you to try this formula
whenever you want. Pick a time.
Let's say if I go a quarter of a circle,
I expect to be moving to the left quarter
of a circle means Omega t is Pi over
two course and a Pi over
two is zero because Casa 90
zero sign up by over two is
one. And I get a speed of Omega art
in the negative either direction,
which is an Omega God wants the speed.
That's indeed the correct.
Dan said you can satisfy yourself
at various times is going like this.
Yeah,
so let's sneak in one
more bit of native here,
which is to take the database to off the
derivative and that's a very important
result. If you do that, uh,
let's take one more deliberative.
Let's try to lose part it and the head
so I can just write down the answer for
take one more date of it to the sign is
going to become a cost sign and yield
and other Omega discourse and is going
to become a minus sign and give me
another omega.
If you do that,
you will find the whole answer as
equal to minus Omega Square Times.
Just
the vector art itself.
That's a very interesting result. It tells
you when a particle moves in a circle,
it has an acceleration in
the negative art direction,
namely directed towards the center.
What's the magnitude of that acceleration?
I write it without an Arrow here.
That's equaled Omega Square Times.
The magnitude of this vector,
which is just our,
but now I can also write
it as we squared over r.
So here ready.
This is a very important formula.
I don't know how many kids generation
after generation get in trouble because
they do not remember the following fact.
So I'm going to say it once more with
feeling when a particle moves in a circle,
it does an acceleration towards the
center of this size B squared over r.
Yeah,
but it's simple. It comes from the
fact that velocity is a vector.
Then you can change your velocity
vector by changing your direction.
It's sparkle is constantly
changing its direction,
but it therefore has an acceleration.
And the acceleration we have shown
here is pointing toward the center.
And the size of that is we squared over r.
So for example,
if a car is going on a racetrack
and you seeing it from the top,
if the gas pedal says 60
miles per hour speedometer,
you might say it's not accelerating.
But that's the lay person's view.
But it was going in a circle.
You will say from now on that Indian
has an acceleration even though no one's
stepping on the accelerator
of Amount v squared over r.
So that's a very important
thing. That's the part, uh,
that's what you're
learning in this course.
The fact that when you step on your gas,
you accelerate.
Everybody knows the fact that when you
go in a circle, you accelerate this.
What we're learning here,
and it's coming from the fact the end
velocity is a vector and there's change
can be due to change in the
magnitude or change in direction.
This is the problem with the magnitude
of velocity was nailed down and fixed at
Omega are the direction
is constantly changing.
Okay, so I'm going to now, uh,
okay,
do a second class of problems.
We will return to this issue later.
By the way,
one thing I should mention to you,
suppose the particle is not
moving in a circle, but does this,
let's take a circle and just
keep a quarter of the circle.
[inaudible] this part,
when you're doing a of a circle,
the supposed to be quarter of a circle,
you have the same acceleration directed
toward the center. In other words,
you don't have to be moving actually in
a circle to have the acceleration at any
instant.
Your motion,
if it follows any curve locally can
be approximated as being part of some
circle,
right?
You can take circles at different size
and place them against your trajectory
and see which one fits.
That's the are we squared over r is the
acceleration directed toward the center
of that circle?
Okay.
One miscellaneous result,
which we don't use very much now,
but which I should mention
to you is the following.
Suppose this is the ground
with some audit in here.
That's a plane with some audits
in here and in the plane.
That is some other object.
What's the location of the object?
Let us say P for Plain d
for ground o for object.
I think it's clear the position of
the object with respect to the ground.
This vector is the same as the position
of the object with respect to the plane.
Let's position of the plane
with respect to the ground.
You agree?
Okay,
this is the pictured here.
Maybe we can start taking dinner with
this of this with respect to time and that
will say the velocity of the
object with respect to the ground.
The last of the object with the SPEC
that the plane by last year, the plane,
it's a Spec to the ground.
That means if you're going in a plan
and you throw something up in the air,
it seems to be going up and down to you,
but if I see you through the glass,
the object is going on some trajectory
which has got both up and down and
horizontal motion and this is
the rule for adding velocities.
So when you have a velocity in the moving
plane frame and you want to find the
velocity on the ground, you should
add to every object in the plane,
the velocity of the plane
with a Spec to the ground.
That's intuitively clear. You use it all
the time, but maybe along one dimension,
but this is the way to
do it in two dimensions.
That may be some simple problem involving
this in the problem with science,
so I'm just going over this. Okay.
The problem we wanted to do today,
whole family of problems looks like this.
I want to consider the particle
which has definite acceleration,
a constant one,
but a is now a vector.
The question I have is what does
this location at all future times?
I think you can tell by analogy with
what I didn't want to mention that the
position of that object or any time t
is going to be the initial position plus
Velocity Times d plus one half
80 square, everything is the same as
in one d except everybody's a vector.
No initial position is a pair of numbers.
Initial velocity is a pair of numbers.
Once you know those, you
can find the position of the
object at all future times.
So let's take one simple example.
Yes.
So that if somebody's in a
car and decided to fly off
and we want to know,
as you can tell,
our concern is where does
the car hit the ground?
When does the car hit the ground?
That's the problem in two dimensions.
So how do we solve this problem?
We pick up origin to be this point here.
Let the height of the building be h cod
is traveling with some initial speed,
be zero in a horizontal direction.
This equation is a part of equation
one along x and one along. Why?
Right for the x part I'm going to write
x is equal zero plus v Zero t and s zero
I'm going to be Tuesday to zero
by choice of my origin being here,
they scored in the cart is the
zero because this is my audition.
Okay.
How about the white coordinate?
The equation for the white cord in
it is the height of the building.
The velocity has no vertical component
that is no v y but it has an acceleration
of mine is g.
So this is the fate of this person
at any given time, t a t equals zero.
You have him right on top of this
edge that all foods at times excellent
proceeds as if nothing happened
and then why you're falling.
And if you want to know something,
like when do you hit the ground?
I think it's fairly clear what
you have to do. For example,
if t star is the time you hit the ground,
then t star satisfies the equation.
H minus one half g do
you start square to zero?
You saw it for the t start from this one
and you put it there and that tells you
where you land. I don't think I
have to actually do that step.
I'm assuming you can fill in the blanks,
right? Solve this equation for t star.
Put it there and that's where you land.
Okay,
that's one class of problems.
So here's the second class.
The second class is the most popular
application of what I'm doing now,
but I want you not to
memorize every formula.
The book gives you what this
problem. That's the problem
with predict tidal marsh
predict tile motion.
You start here and you find a predict
tile with some velocity be not at some
data and it's going to go up
and it's going to come down.
One question is where
does it go into land?
Other question is at what angle
should you find your project child?
So we'll go the furthest
so you can find the equation,
but you got to think a little
bit before you solve everything.
It's good to have an
idea of what's coming.
So you imagine you've got this
monster cannon fire things.
It's got a fixed speed being art and how
do you want aim it so you can be most
effective as far as you can.
Well there are two schools of thought.
Okay, one says aim at your
enemy and fire like this.
Then it lands on your foot
because assuming the candidate
has said zero height,
the cannon balls certainly
comes out towards the enemy
but has no time of flight.
Yeah,
other one says maximize the time of flight
and you point, it can't end like this.
So it goes up, stays in the ad for a very
long time, but it falls on your head.
So we know the truth is somewhere between
zero and 90 a naive guests may be 45
but turns out naive is actually correct.
So I just wanted to show
you how that comes out,
but I don't want you to cram this formula.
This is the kind of thing
you should be able to deduce.
Let's go back to the same
thing I wrote earlier.
X equals zero plus.
What's the hardest onto velocity?
Horizontal Velocity is v
zero cost science data.
So x is v Zero Course [inaudible] times
t and Y is v zero sine theta famous t
minus one half g t square.
Okay, so now we know everything about
this particular, I told you once,
you know the three parameters
are not in be knocked.
You know everything about
the future of the object.
So let's ask what's the
range ranges that distance.
So what's the strategy for rain?
You see how long you are in the air and
the whole time you're in the air you're
travelling horizontally at the speed.
So again,
let t star be the time
when you hit the ground.
So you said Zero Equals v zero
scientists that minus one half g t star
[inaudible] star.
I just pulled out a common tea
so I'd say so you on the
ground on two occasions.
One is initially we are
not interested in that.
Well if the time they are interested in
is not zero yet allowed to cancel it and
get the time from here and that time is
t star equals to v zero scientists over
g.
That's how long you had in the air.
This says if you want to be in the air
for a long time, maximize sine theta,
so you may think it's 90 degrees is the
best angle, but that's not the goal.
Goal is to get the biggest rain to go
back to x and put your family for t star,
which is two v zero scientists over g
and that becomes B Zero Square over g
times to sign theotokos sine theta.
If you go back to your trigonometry,
you should find that is really
the formula for sign to Tatum.
That's another example of where knowing
the true guidance is very helpful.
Okay,
so this tells you exactly what you want.
It says make sign to
data as big as you want,
and that tells you who
theta is going to be.
90 and data's going to be 45 but it's
not from a naive guests that it's halfway
between zero and 90 turns out to be.
This are the fairly complicated balance
between the time of flight and the range.
So some people memorize this.
I would say don't do that because after
a while you won't have room in your head
for anything.
Just go back as often as possible to this
formula and work your way from there.
No, there's more variations,
but it's always the same thing.
Here's another variation in my days.
They will say,
find out when you want an
object to go through that point.
And I tell you the muzzle
Velocity v not what are our,
I tell you at what angle I fired it.
I want you to find the
speed so it'll land here.
So how would you do that problem?
You do that problem by saying,
suppose this actually happens
at some time. T at that time,
t the x coordinate must
have a certain value.
They go to the ECC creation
and demand that this vehicle,
the desired x value and find the time.
I take the time and put it in the white
equation and demand that the why I get
agree with this. Why if you do that,
you will find that it's one
unknown, which is v. Dot.
And they can consult for Bina.
This is the most general problems.
You can have the textbook,
of course people make them interesting.
Suddenly there's a mountain
and that's the physicist
hiking on this mountain. See,
you're already laughing. So it's not a
very credible problem that we don't hike.
And when we get stuck, we don't want food.
We want our table of integral switch.
What we want somebody to sent to us.
So these problems are
embellished in many ways, uh,
to make you all feel involved.
For example,
instead of a stone dropping nowadays,
there's a monkey that's falling down.
So the people in life sciences field,
hey we are, we are represented in this,
but all those creatures with a very
interesting, in the end you are told,
you know that's a hard set inside a
railway carriage and you cannot see the
horse but the horse is moving.
You can deduce it because the
candidate is moving the other way.
Does it picked it up? A horse picture
of a carriage, all the glossy stuff.
Then it says treat the
horses, appoint particle. See,
that's what we learned in the old days.
But nowadays it's a hardest.
But in the end if you're going to treat
this appoint particular seems to meet
the real waste. If you're
the Godfather, right?
You want to get the
contract for Johnny Fontane.
You don't tell your constant Larry a
Tom put a point particle on Jack's bed,
right? When you want a horse, use
ours. When you want to point particle,
if you wake up and find a point particle
on your bed, what's the reaction?
So I think these extra pictures,
sometimes they're helpful.
Sometimes they just,
the cost make the book costs a lot more.
That are problems where
the hearts must be treated.
We will see when we study rigid bodies,
even their horse is not really a rigid
body unless it's been dead for a long
time. At least there. The fact it's
not a point particular is important.
So I think reason books
are bigger and bigger,
but still do the same information to set
examples are more than more interesting.
Sometimes they serve a purpose,
sometimes they're distracting,
but I haven't written a book in this
field, so I will not say anything more.